what's up believe nation happy Friday
just wanted to make a quick video for my
Toronto fans I've done a lot of meetups
whenever I go into a new city I try to
do a meet-up I almost had one in Dallas
but that got cancelled very sad but in
general when I travel around and try to
do a meet-up because meeting with you
guys is one of my favorite things to do
I love hearing your stories I love
taking pictures I love just seeing the
faces behind the comments and the likes
and the clicks it's awesome making the
one-on-one connection I'm physically
based here in Toronto most of the time
but I don't really do much in Toronto
most of the stuff I do is the
International and so I thought you know
what I'm filming this coming Wednesday
at the Toronto dance Elsa studio and I
thought I'm gonna do a quick event for
anybody in Toronto who wants to come out
I'm feeling so you get to see how my
setup actually looks from 8:30 to at
least 3 o'clock
Michael later but that's the confirm
time and if you guys want to stop by say
hi be in the background on some videos
maybe take some pictures do some book
signings answer some quick questions I'm
working that day so I might have a sign
on the door that says like filming in
progress but I'm going to take breaks
and come outside and see who's there and
look forward to quickly meeting you if
you're in the city and want to say hi
and I'd like to see some of you in the
background of my videos people think
it's a green screen but it's not it's a
it's a natural location trying to dance
salsa it's business I own so the event
is happening next Wednesday I'm gonna
link up in the description a link to a
Facebook event page where you guys can
go and has it has all the details
you can sign up there's no fee and
looking forward to meeting you and for
the international friends hopefully I'll
come to your city soon but if you want
to come to Toronto I'll see you
Wednesday thank you guys for the love
continue to believe and whatever your
one where it is see you soon
PS this guy is going to be there too so
if you've ever wanted to see a real live
Timo up close and personal this is your
show one little small community have the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple so it
would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details